Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
So, aber bist du eigentlich Optimist?
Eigentlich schon.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 449 vom 23. Dezember 2022.
Jetzt habe ich auch mal 2000 gesagt, um alle glücklich zu machen. Es weihnachtet sehr und das neue Jahr kommt. Yay, hurra, das neue Jahr, super.
Ja!
Ich würde sagen, Tim, wer hat uns verraten? die goldenen 20 haben.
Nachdem wir ja schon mit 2020 so unzufrieden waren, dass 2021 nur so bedingt Höhepunkte liefern konnte, war das dann so in diesem Jahr mit dem Optimismus auch nochmal ein richtiger Test.
Jo, die goldene Zwanziger kommt eh immer erst ein bisschen später.
Die Tesla-Aktionäre haben jetzt auch die Sinus-Kurve.
Aber sie kommen. Nee, nee, das wird alles gut. Ich glaube sehr an die Sinus Kurve.
Du nicht, oder was?
Generell die Aktionäre. Ja, ich meine, das ist immer so eine Sache, wie man so auf die Welt blickt.
Ich sag mal so, es macht ja Sinn, an die Sinuskurve zu glauben.
Und ich finde, manche Diskurse werden auch nicht unbedingt dadurch besser, dass sie
Pessimismus durchtränkt sind.
Was heißt stellt sich raus also zu irgendeinem späteren Zeitpunkt meinst du dann dass sich das rausgestellt hat? Ja, also das wird auch schon ein bisschen zu spät ausgestellt.
Aber wenn du aber auf der Sinuskurve bist und du weißt nicht, wo der Nullpunkt ist,
Ja, dann ist es halt schwierig, weil du die ganze Zeit denkst, boah, jetzt sind wir aber bestimmt am unteren Scheitelpunkt. Und stellt sich raus, mhm.
Also zu irgendeinem späteren Zeitpunkt meinst du dann, dass sich das rausgestellt hat, aber.
Ja, richtig, dann denkst du, du wärst jetzt am unteren Schaltepunkt.
Dann kann es ja auch gleich schon wieder hochgehen. Also das ist ja so das Ding.
Also von daher ist es auf jeden Fall auch nicht angemessen, immer zu glauben, es würde jetzt permanent bergab gehen, weil es geht eh nicht permanent bergab.
Eigentlich würde ich sagen, es ist nicht permanent bergab, weil es ist ja auch nicht permanent bergab. Aber es ist ja auch nicht permanent bergab, weil es ist ja auch nicht permanent bergab.
Permanent bergab. Eigentlich wird ja immer alles besser.
Ja, nehmt sie, merkt das doch.
So langfristig meine das mag natürlich jetzt auch nur so einen, wie soll ich sagen,
was weiß ich so, dass so die letzten 50 Jahre, wenn man so in Deutschland gelebt hat, so hat man ja dann doch eher einen gesamt positiven Verlauf. Nicht, dass es nicht auch
negative Trends gegeben hätte, aber es ist ja an sich, verbessern sich Dinge eigentlich auch die ganze Zeit immer wieder und das darf man dabei nicht vergessen. Vor allem kommen,
die guten Sachen kommen dann auch immer plötzlich und unerwartet, obwohl sie sich lange abgezeichnet haben. Aber man ist dann doch mal so ein bisschen überrascht, wenn sie dann passieren, dass sie dann so auf einmal so plopp da sind.
Ja, natürlich ist man überrascht, wenn ausnahmsweise mal was Positives passiert.
Aber ich kann auch sagen, ich bin von vielen negativen Dingen auch überrascht gewesen. Also jetzt ist einmal die Überraschung ist jetzt nicht ein Abonnement des Positiven.
Ich weiß nicht, ich bin immer noch sehr unerschütterlich, was meinen Optimismus angeht. Ich bin immer davon überzeugt, dass alle anderen Ereignisse immer nur vorübergehende Erscheinungen sind.
Ich sag mal so, die Lage ist so ernst, dass man jetzt, naja, dass ich langsam bereit bin.
Nur noch Witze drüber machen kann.
Klamotten anzubieten. Eine immer wieder vorgebrachte Feststellung, dass ich nur,
schwarz trage und den bunten Kleidungsstücken abgeneigt bin.
Dass wir jetzt sogar hier die Einhorn-Standarte Regenbogen-T-Shirts machen,
dass das ist wirklich dramatisch schlecht ist.
Das ist doch ein klares Signal.
Also ich bin auf jeden Fall optimistisch für das neue Jahr. Das wird schon... Krieg wird beendet werden. All diese Dinge.
Wie wird der Krieg beendet? Das klingt nicht gut.
Plötzlich. Aber... Aber es zieht sich halt noch ein bisschen dahin.
Also plötzliches Kriegsende ist häufig äh...
Naja, ich meine, dieser Krieg ist ja sozusagen nur so lange, wie sich alle gegen sein Ende stemmen. Und dieses Moment wird dann irgendwann einfach wegfallen.
Und dann ist es auf einmal vorbei.
Nee, klar.
Also siehst du schon, ich bin unerschütterlicher Optimist. Das ist einfach für mich vollkommen unverständlich. Ich akzeptiere auch für mein Lebensbild irgendwie gar nichts anderes. Und so schlecht bin ich damit auch bisher nicht gefahren.
Ich denke, das ist auch etwas, was einem Kraft gibt und was... Ja, einem so im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes auch am Leben erhält.
Also ich würde gar nicht anders leben wollen. Weil wenn man immer die ganze Zeit nur mit dem Kopf nach unten gesenkt und alles ist Scheiße. Wo willst du denn dann auch die Energie hernehmen, irgendwas zu verbessern?
Das ist absolut richtig und natürlich habe ich diesen relativ positiven Blick auf die Dinge ja eigentlich auch, aber ich muss sagen, dass es doch zunehmend schwieriger wird in diesen Zeiten.
Ja, ja, ne. Ich denke nicht. Ich denke, es hat sich eigentlich gar nichts, eigentlich gar nichts
wirklich generell daran geändert. Man muss halt einfach positiv in die Zukunft schauen.
Ich werde das auf jeden Fall weiterhin tun. Du bist natürlich für schlechte Nachrichten zuständig.
Haben wir denn schlechte Nachrichten?
Wir haben gute Nachrichten.
Na komm, siehst du jetzt geht es doch schon los.
Also, eine. Hast du noch dieses Jingle?
Mit der guten Nachricht!
Gute Nachrichten.
Wir haben von zwei Männern berichtet, die Google-Fonds-Abmahnungen versendet haben. 170 Euro.
Von unbescholtenen Mittelständlern erpresst haben. Und da gab es jetzt eine, was ist es?
Hausdurchsuchung gab es, ja. Also es sind zwei Männer, die haben am 21. Dezember 22 Besuch,
bekommen. Und zwar wurden ihre Unterkünfte in Berlin, Hannover, Ratzeburg und Baden-Baden.
Durchsucht, des Rechtsanwalts Kilian Lenard und seinem Mandanten Martin Ismail,
der Martin Ismail hat eine Organisation gegründet mit dem Namen IG-Datenschutz,
also Interessengemeinschaft Datenschutz und deren Interessen hat der Rechtsanwalt Kilian
Lennart vertreten mit diesen Webseiten-Abmahnungen. Mehr oder weniger Schmerzensgeld wegen Verletzung
des Rechts auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung. Und offenbar haben sie laut der Polizei,
die ermittelt von wegen des versuchten Abmahnbetrugs und der versuchten Erpressung,
beziehungsweise teilweise ist ja versucht und dann ist es bei denen, die bezahlt haben.
Auch dann nicht mehr versucht. In mindestens 2418 Fällen und da gibt es zwei Arrestbeschlüsse
mit einer und gehen von einer Gesamtsumme von 346.000 Euro aus. Es lagen 420 Strafanzeigen
von Betroffenen vor und ja, etwa 2000 Personen haben das, dieses Vergleichsangebot von 1.000,
von 170 Euro eben, ja, sind darauf eingegangen, ja. Und haben das bezahlt. Tatsächlich kenne
auch eine Person, die davon betroffen war und auch entgegen meinem Rat bezahlt hat. Aber das ist
tatsächlich, also war eher so, wollte keinen Stress haben und hat es den Leuten gegönnt. Wäre
schön, wenn die jetzt ihr Geld zurückbekommt. Und das ist eine gute Nachricht. Das sind
Erpressungsmethoden und ich finde es erfreulich, dass jemand, das sich hier die Berliner Polizei
bemüht hat, die Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Berlin, bemüht hat, dem nachzugehen und ich hoffe.
Dass die Bitterböse bestraft werden, weil wer so das Recht missbraucht, der tut der Gesamtheit,
keinen Gefallen. Und auch der Rechtspflege keinen Gefallen. Und da würde ich mich freuen,
wenn das bitterböse Konsequenzen für diese Menschen hätte. Das würde mein Vertrauen in den Rechtsstaat stärken.
Ja, ist schon mal ganz schön, dass die Staatsanwaltschaft explizit schreibt, dass ja hier Bots verwandelt worden sind,
also dass quasi durch eine Software automatisiert alles gecheckt wurde und
Da ist ja gar kein abmahnfähiger Schaden entstanden.
Natürlich, die haben irgendeinen Scanner gehabt.
Also es ist halt so, weißt du, das ist, als würde sie in den USA irgendwie automatisiert,
Gehwege oder, also genau, ich glaube, das ist, als würdest du automatisiert Gehwege suchen, wo noch Eis liegt,
um dann da hinzugehen, dich auf die Fresse zu legen und zu sagen, hier, das hat mir jetzt wehgetan. Aber wenn du, es ist ja auch relativ klar,
das, also die sind ja auch ein bisschen doof, ne. Wenn dieser Martin Ismail mal mit seiner Datendingens da. Wenn er 2400 Webseiten besucht und sich dabei 2400 schwerwiegende,
Persönlichkeitsrechtsverletzungen erleidet, dann ist ja auch irgendwie klar, dass jede,
Staatsanwaltschaft dann irgendwann auch mal fragt, wie der sich von diesem ganzen schweren
Schaden noch erholen will. Das ist ja wirklich der arme Mann.
All die Schmerzen!
Also dann fragt man sich ja, wie schwer der traumatisiert sein will, wenn der,
immer weiter doom scrollt und sich durchs Internet klickt und irgendwelche
was weiß ich, kleine Berliner Gastro-Einrichtungen besucht.
Herr Ismail, nachdem Sie das 2418. Mal auf dem Eis ausgerutscht sind, haben Sie sich überlegt, 18. Mal auf dem Eis ausgerutscht sind, haben sie sich überlegt mal Spikes zuzulegen.
Ja, wir sind sie. Wie konnten sie dann noch 500 Kilometer fahren um sich um die nächste Eisfläche? Also ja, das ist schön. Und es wäre schön, wenn sowas jetzt auch mal gegen,
gegen die sehr viel besser organisierte Kriminalität sage, dann kriege ich bestimmt eine Abmahnung,
von Waldorf-Rommer. Deswegen sage ich das nicht. Aber gegen solche Leute mit viel höheren Organisierungsgrad.
Das wäre schön, wenn man gegen die auch mal vorgehen würde.
Und Automatisierungsgrad.
Das wäre doch erfreulich. könnte man doch mal was machen.
Ja, okay, so viel zu guten Nachrichten.
Ja.
Macht ja jetzt was selber gegen sich.
Nicht so viel machen kann man gegen Elon Musk bisher. Allerdings, man könnte ihn so tun, als würde man ihn abwählen.
Ja, also, da gab es ja viele, die so meinten, ja, man konnte so tun und so weiter.
Und er hat das jetzt irgendwie, also ich denke, dass der, dass der, also ich bleibe dabei, dass
der das mit dieser Abwahl schon durchaus gewissermaßen ernst gemeint hat oder ernsthaft die Antwort haben
wollte. Er hat ja getwittert, das haben wir glaube ich in der letzten Sendung, haben wir das schon besprochen, war das kurz darauf, dass er hat wieder einen Poll gemacht, hat gesagt, soll ich als CEO
hier zurücktreten, ich werde mich an das Ergebnis dieses Polls halten.
Und dann kam halt raus, was war das Ergebnis? 58 oder 57 Prozent haben gesagt, wäre nicht.
57 Prozent.
Schlecht?
Geh mal.
Wobei es ja hier nur darum geht, ob er CEO bleibt von Twitter, nicht ob er jetzt Twitter wieder verkauft. Das ist eine Frage des Preises.
Naja, das Ding ist glaube ich unverkäuflich inzwischen.
Ja, das ist korrekt.
Ja, aber ich meine selbst für sehr geringere, selbst für, also er ist nicht gut da drin, Twitter oder Jobs bei Twitter gut zu verkaufen.
Er hat ja dann auch gesagt, okay, nachdem das Ergebnis dann kam, dann hat er erst mal 24 Stunden nicht getwittert, was auch dann schon wieder eine Meldung wert war.
Breaking News, Elon Musk hat nichts getwittert.
So, ist der Tod, ist der, hat er jetzt Kopfpfefe?
Und dann hat er ja bekannt gegeben, er tritt zurück, sobald er jemanden findet, der blöd
genug ist, den Job anzunehmen.
Das ist korrekt, aber ich sag mal, spätestens wenn er jetzt wirklich jemanden sucht.
Ja, ich meine, da hat er Recht. Ich meine, wer will denn eigentlich schon für Elon Musk ausgerechnet in diesem verbrannten Stuhl irgendwie antreten?
So. oben.
Also wer sagt denn, also ich mein, wer auch immer das jetzt macht, weiß, dass es halt,
in allen Nachrichten steht, als der Typ der blöd genug ist, diesen Job anzunehmen.
Ja, es ist schon mal klar, dass du dich da unter zu ordnen hast. Du musst das schon mal mit gesenken Haupt reinmarschieren und vielleicht ohne Waschschüssel irgendwie in der Hand.
So ein Rapper.
Ich fand übrigens sehr schön, das war eigentlich mein Lieblings-Tweet, der kam von, kennst du,
Snoop Doggy Dog? Snoop Doggy, das nennt er sich seit zwei Jahrzehnten nur noch. Kennste den, ne? Der twitterte dann einfach einen Poll, should I run Twitter? Was ich echt gut finde.
Weil Snoop Dogg als CEO von Twitter fände ich auf jeden Fall, also da wird es auf jeden nicht langweilig.
Ich meine, langweilig ist es ja jetzt mit Elon Musk auch nicht gerade unbedingt.
Nee, aber der Snoop Dogg ist nicht so ein Hitzkopf. Der sitzt in der Regel relativ entspannt in der Ecke.
Der ist immer relativ gechillt.
Der raucht eben eine größere Kräuterzigarette und verschiebt die Probleme auf morgen.
Und der hat 81% Approval Rating.
Bei Twitter.
Bei Twitter. Ach so durch diesen Poll oder was?
Na ja, da werden doch jetzt die Entscheidungen getroffen.
Ach so, ja stimmt, das ist ja jetzt Gottes Wille und so.
Ja, ist natürlich schlecht, wenn der Vox dir dann den Popo liefert so.
Volkspopuli hatten wir schon bald.
Also ich glaube, das ist schön.
Also ich denke, das wird passieren.
Aber was ich sehr schön fand, ist ja dann Elon Musk. Ne, nicht Elon Musk. Wie heißt der?
Kim.com. Kim.com sagte dann, ja Kimmel meinte dann so sinngemäß, ja, also Elon Musk, er könne.
Kimbeleis, ja.
Sich das nicht anders erklären, als dass Elon Musk jetzt hier quasi so ein Honeypot für die
ganzen Bots gemacht hat, um die einfacher zu identifizieren, weil die ja alle sagen, weil die ja alle damit stimmen werden, er solle zurücktreten als Head of Twitter.
Und anders konnte sich Kimmel das natürlich nicht erklären und schlug dann vor, er solle.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Doch wenigstens sicherstellen, dass man bezahlen muss, wenn man mitstimmen darf.
Oder dass man quasi sein Stimmrecht bezahlen muss, weil das würde es eben dann für den Deep State unmöglich machen mit seinen Bot-Armeen hier dafür zu wirken, dass er
daraufhin zu wirken, dass er zurücktritt.
Alter Kimbel, das ist wirklich auch so ein Vogel.
Jedenfalls fand Elon Musk, dass er sowohl seiner Aufmerksamkeit als auch seiner Reichweite würde ich ist und schloss sich dieser Idee an und sagte also, er fände diese These interessant
und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, hat er dann auch in Aussicht gestellt, dass er das mit den nur zahlenden Nutzer dürfen abstimmen auch so relevant fand. Oder? Habe
ich das richtig verstanden, Tim?
Also das Ding mit seinen ganzen Ankündigungen, was jetzt irgendwie angeblich getan wird,
das scheint ja auch alles keine große Halbwertzeit zu haben. Von daher gebe ich da jetzt erst mal nicht so sehr viel drauf.
Diese ganzen Links auf andere Plattformen sind jetzt verboten, was der Twitter-Support dann auch schon rausgehauen hat. Wurde ja auch nach ein paar Stunden dann auch schon wieder kassiert. Zumindest gegen diese Tweets weg.
Ich glaube diese Bands auf die Masterlohn Links, die existieren noch. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das heute noch nicht wieder...
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Man kann wieder Mastlone-Links posten.
Es ist auch schon wieder weggenommen worden, weil da kam dann ja auch die EU.
Ja, diese und diese Regel wurde auch, die haben sie einfach wieder von der Webseite genommen.
Ja, weil ich meine, das hätte auch nicht lange Bestand gehabt, weil das ist sozusagen mal gegen EU-Recht. Du musst explizit das auch erlauben, dass man auch auf andere Dienste verweisen darf
und da hätten sie sich jetzt in 0,X nochmal eine Riesenstrafe eingefangen, wenn sie da
nicht mal ganz schnell drauf reagiert hätten. Von daher merkt er glaube ich auch so ein bisschen oder man könnte auch sagen er testet es aus, wo so die Grenzen des Schalten und Walten sind. Und auf der einen Seite hast du halt die Zwänge des Kommerzes, dass eben die Werbepartner nicht bei einem mitziehen und auch das Rechts so,
zumindest das Rechts in Europa, was halt diesen Plattformen überhaupt mal im Prinzip ein bisschen
was entgegensetzt, was ja in den USA nicht in demselben Maße immer gegeben zu sein scheint.
Ja und dann hast du halt noch die unerbildliche Macht der Streisand, die über dich herrscht.
Ja, wenn du es erstmal in die Welt gebracht hast, versuchst es unterzukriegen. Also Mastodon hat sich auf jeden Fall sehr gefreut über diese Promo. Also gebannt zu sein auf Twitter, das war sicherlich nicht das schlechteste für das Netzwerk. Jetzt hat auch noch die
Letzte davon gehört, dass es das gibt. Naja, keine Zahlen. Ich meine, es gibt keine Zahlen. Wie auch, aber wäre mal echt interessant zu sehen, ob es wirklich,
eine Bremse bei Neue-Account-Anlegungen oder vielleicht sogar eine Steigerung bei
gelöschten Accounts oder Abandoned-Accounts gibt. Das weiß nur Twitter,
da wird er wahrscheinlich nicht drüber twitteren.
Also er wird sich ja jetzt zurückziehen wahrscheinlich irgendwann.
Er hat aber ohnehin schon seine Goons da installiert.
Also es wird so ein bisschen berichtet über welche Leute er da so hat, die er da jetzt irgendwie bei Twitter einheizen lässt.
Das sind mitunter Weggefährten, die er schon relativ lang hat, mitunter welche, die er noch nicht so lang hat, aber die in seinem Sinne schalten und walten.
Und die werden potenziell da einfach auch übernehmen. Tesla-Aktien so günstig wie nie. Elon Musk nicht mehr reichster Mensch des Planeten. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das erwähnt hatten.
Nö, aber das ist schon... Das ist eine der relevanten Schwellen, die er auf dem Weg zum.
Ja gut, das ist für mich auch nicht so eine relevante Größe.
Millionär nehmen muss.
Wichtiger Marker.
Ich wäre so gerne Millionär. Keine Ahnung, meinetwegen.
So, dann hat er jetzt ja auch noch, also dann wurden die Twitter-Files.
Ja, also wir haben das jetzt irgendwie mehrmals erwähnt, dass das alles einfach,
Wie nennt man das? Also Nothing Burger nennt man das.
Also für mich ist das ein bisschen unübersichtlich, aber was sie halt gemacht haben, ist, dass
jetzt auf einmal in den E-Mail-Archiven des Unternehmens graben und dort,
irgendwelche Dinge rausbringen, wie im Moderation-Team und an anderen Stellen bestimmte Entscheidungen gefällt wurden. Und das machte am Anfang auch alles
erstmal so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob sie da wieder zu ihrer Right-Wing-Crowd catern wollen, indem dann halt wieder mit irgendwie der Umgang mit dem Laptop von Hunter Biden kam. Da dachte ich auch schon so, okay, gut,
jetzt die olle Kamelle wird wieder rausgezogen, die ich damals auch schon nicht so verfolgt habe,
steckt da nicht so drin in diesen Details, was da hin und her geworfen wird. Ja und generell gibt es halt viele Debatten darüber, was denn nun intern bei Twitter in den letzten Jahren so gelaufen sei
bezüglich eines Shadow-Bannings bestimmter Accounts oder eben auch dem Puschen bestimmter Accounts.
Es gibt ja auch diese Meldung, dass irgendwelche amerikanischen Militäraccounts, die im arabischen Raum unterwegs sind, dass die irgendwie von einer algorithmischen Zurückstufung ausgenommen wurden, berichtet El-Jazeera.
Teilweise auch verifiziert wurden,
sogar. Also nicht nur von der algorithmischen Abgrenzung, sondern auch quasi tatsächlich ein Härchen bekommen haben.
Sie haben ja wahrscheinlich 8 Dollar überwiesen dafür.
Und, na, und, dass sie die, naja, das gab's ja damals noch nicht. Also das ist schon.
Sagen wir mal komisch, dass da irgendwelche, dass da irgendwelche Faults-Flag-Operationen,
von US-Militär und FBI, also das FBI hat Accounts gemeldet, wo sie gesagt haben, hier,
da stimmt irgendwas nicht, die wurden dann irgendwie quasi in ihrer Reichweite beschränkt.
Gleichzeitig hat das Department of Defense irgendwelche Accounts gemeldet, mit denen
sie Informationen oder nicht gleichzeitig, aber eben auch, dass hat das Department of
Defense irgendwelche Accounts gemeldet, mit denen sie irgendwie zum Beispiel verbreiten,
dass ja die Drohnenmorde akkurat wären und nur gegen Terroristen und nicht gegen Zivilisten
eingesetzt werden. Ja, das ist halt Fake News. So, das muss man ganz klar sagen.
Und diese Fake News zu verbreiten, da gab es offenbar eine direkte Liaison zwischen den
Pentagon-Leuten und Twitter.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass das für jede government-organized-False-Flagg-Aktion gilt. Gleichzeitig, also ich glaube nicht, dass jetzt andere Regierungen sich bei Twitter
melden können und sagen können, hier übrigens unsere neue Forge-Flag-Aktion, machen wir einen blauen Haken dran.
So, dass das aber die US-Amerikaner machen können mit einer Silicon Valley Company, Ist jetzt auch nicht so enorm überraschend, oder?
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Ich meine, die Vorstellung davon, dass ein Unternehmen vollständig unabhängig agieren kann in dem Land, in dem es beheimatet ist
und dass die Mitarbeiter dort auch komplett wertfrei agieren, davon sollte man sich, glaube ich, von vornherein schon mal trennen, abgesehen davon, dass es natürlich auch immer wieder Druckmittel gibt auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise.
Also du bewegst dich da nicht nur in dem eigenen Kosmos.
Trotzdem ist das natürlich bedenklich.
Auf jeden Fall.
Die Frage ist halt nur, an welcher Stelle nimmt das bedrohliche Ausmaße an? Ich meine, wenn jetzt irgendein Account ein bisschen anders gewichtet wird im Algorithmus, dann dreht sich davon die Welt nicht um.
Trotzdem ist es natürlich ein Prozess, der eigentlich klare Regeln haben sollte, die man dann auch am besten kommunizieren sollte.
Und das ist in diesem Fall unter Garantie nicht passiert. Und dass es natürlich jetzt innerhalb des Twitter-Stabs Diskussionen gibt, jetzt zum Beispiel zu den Ereignissen vom 6.
Januar, was ja dann auch dazu führte, dass Trumps Account geblockt wurde, gerade so als er abgewählt war sozusagen, dass es in einer Silicon Valley Bude dann darüber heftige,
politische Diskussionen darüber gibt, wie man damit umgeht, das halte ich für absolut nachvollziehbar.
Und jetzt ist natürlich so ein privates Unternehmen, hat ja in dem Sinne keinerlei gesetzliche Vorgaben moralisch in irgendeiner Form in die oder in die Richtung zu schlagen.
Das ist ja dann deine eigene Entscheidung, was du machst mit deinem Ding da.
Nur, dass es natürlich mittlerweile alles so hochpolitisch geworden ist, wo diese Plattformen ebenso groß sind. Das haben wir bei Facebook am Anfang gesehen und bei Twitter natürlich auch.
Und wir haben das ja auch schon mehrfach diskutiert und es gibt auch keine einfachen Antworten.
Also, weil du immer in dieser Zwickmühle mit machst du nichts, dann lieferst du den Leuten sozusagen
dem Mob und dem Algorithmus aus. Dieses ganze Spiel mit Meinungsfreiheit, was Elon Musk jetzt ja auch ins Feld bringt.
Hat ja auch damit zu tun mit, wir tun nichts, wenn Leute misshandelt werden, wir tun nichts, wenn Leute gemobbt werden etc.
Und das kann es ja auch nicht sein. Und das ist ja auch so eine Position, die bei Twitter Jahre gedauert hat, bis sie dann überhaupt mal so richtig ins Rollen kam. Dann haben sie über die Jahre Verbesserungen vorgenommen.
Und das sind natürlich alles Eingriffe in die Kommunikation und die Folgen einem gewissen moralischen Kompass, den du als Unternehmen dann eben hast oder nicht. Und der kann dann so positiv sein, dass vielleicht bestimmte Leute daran nicht mehr teilnehmen
wollen an diesem Marktplatz. Der kann so negativ sein, dass er gegen Gesetze verstößt oder dass er zumindest solche Ausmaße annimmt, dass dann eben auch die Politik meint, das,
muss jetzt auch mal gesetzlich geregelt werden, wie wir das ja hier in Deutschland auch gesehen haben, damit das Netzwerkt durchsetzungsgesetz, das ist ja alles der Versuch in irgendeiner
Form dieser Übergriffigkeit auf diesen wichtigen Plattformen, wo Leute ja ihre Identitäten zu leben, in irgendeiner Form hubhaft zu werden. Und das ist ein Prozess, der sich weltweit noch,
abspielt, wie wir das eigentlich als Gesellschaft handeln wollen. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass wir da schon alle Antworten drauf haben. Dass man jetzt in den Twitter-Falls rumgräbt und E-Mails findet.
Ja, wobei ich jetzt sage mal, so False-Flag-Aktionen des US-Militärs unterliegen jetzt üblicherweise.
Über diesen Diskurs, wundert mich ehrlich gesagt kaum.
Nicht in einem gesellschaftlichen Diskurs.
Das ist, nein, das meinte ich damit jetzt auch nicht.
Das ist halt spezifisch so, dass bei Twitter eher so ist, dass sie immer gesagt haben, dass sie gegen jegliche Form der Government-Beeinflussung massiv vorgehen.
Das alles verhindern und so weiter. Und überraschend meinten sie dann doch nur die alle anderen
als US-Amerikanischen. Und das ist übrigens auch der Grund, warum jetzt alle in Sorge,
sind, dass das nächste massive soziale Netzwerk hier irgendwie TikTok ist, was aus China kommt.
Natürlich genau wissen und ich denke da kann man auch wirklich immer ganz gut mal hinhören,
ja wenn so die USA jetzt sagen, ey hier Vorsicht, die Chinesen mit ihrem TikTok,
den kannst du nicht trauen, deinstallieren und so weiter, ja. Also dann musst du im Zweifelsfall
das automatisiert auf das Risiko übertragen, was es für dich bedeutet, wenn du nicht Amerikaner bist,
und Facebook oder Twitter nutzt. Natürlich ist das...
Ja voll gemein, die Chinesen wollen jetzt genau das gleiche machen wie wir.
Frechheit!
Ja, oder wenn die sagen, ey Leute, die installiert Huawei, seien die bescheuert, ist das gefährlich? Ja, dass du eigentlich sagen musst, okay, was bedeutet das also für unser Land,
wenn wir Cisco-Kram benutzen. Das kannst du im Zweifelsfall 1 zu 1 übersetzen.
Ja, aber Globalisierung hat jetzt nicht mehr so den großen Ruf und ich glaube, das wird so ein bisschen der Trend sein in den nächsten Jahren.
Das wird sich dann auch in Digitalien abzeichnen, dass einfach wir wieder vereinzelte Subgruppen dieser globalen Gemeinschaft sehen werden. Also wird sich, glaube ich, der chinesische Raum und der russische Raum
sowieso und der westliche Raum wieder stärker voneinander abgrenzen.
Was? Tja, ich also ich kann ich bin mal gespannt, ob das eine positive oder eine negative Entwicklung
ist. Ich war jetzt nicht unbedingt irgendwie Globalist, wobei das ja auch leider ein sehr stark belasteter Begriff ist, den wir nicht verwenden können, weil er von irgendwelchen
Vollidioten verwendet wird für für irgendwelche weiteren Verschwörungstheorien. Deswegen entschuldige
ich das, ja, aber ich kann kein Anhänger der Globalisierung, aber man muss natürlich schon auch zu anerkennen, dass die in vielen Teilen der Erde einige negative, aber auch
eine ganze Menge positiver Effekte hatte.
Das ist auf jeden Fall jetzt nicht nur gut oder nur schlecht, sondern das ist halt wie immer alles sehr fein abgestuft.
Man muss halt gucken, auf welchen Aspekt man jetzt schaut.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall gespannt, was das eben für die Zukunft bedeutet.
Genau, aber jetzt schauen wir erstmal, was das für Twitter bedeutet. Also ich glaube, was Twitter und 2023 betrifft, das lässt sich alles noch sehr schwer vorhersagen.
Meine Hoffnung wäre, dass in irgendeiner Form zumindest erst mal da so ein CEO reinkommt, der einfach mal ganz normal walten kann und eigentlich müsste er oder sie dieses Unternehmen,
eigentlich mehr oder weniger dahin führen, wo es vorher auch schon war.
Anders sehe ich da gar kein Überleben.
Ja, aber weißt du, für wen 2023 echt gut gelaufen ist, fällt mir gerade mal ein?
Ja, das stimmt allerdings.
Für alle, die Twitter-Aktien hatten. Das ist da enorm gelaufen.
Der Scheißladen war auf der Hälfte seines Werts, wurde dann von diesen Idioten gekauft und wird seitdem zu klump geschlagen. Also, da kannst du wirklich froh sein, wenn du aus der Nummer rausgekommen bist, oder?
Die sitzen da, die kommen aus dem Lachen nicht mehr raus ey. 2023, bestes Cheers!
Bis auf die paar Vögel, die sie noch nicht mal verkauft haben, sondern sich irgendwie
das in Beteiligung umgewandelt haben. Wie dieser Jack Dorsey, den ich sowieso nicht verstehe.
Viel Spaß. Injectors, die kann auf jeden Fall. Okay, aber der Typ ist eh, der hat auch kein Mitleid.
Naja. oder beinends.
Na gut, ja. Kommen wir zu, also ich glaube, genau, wir haben jetzt hier die US-Einmischerei behandelt.
Kommen wir zu den klassischen Dystopien.
Ach so, genau, dann haben sie noch, ach, dann gab es noch, nee, dann gab es auch noch eine Sache. Also neben dieser, dass die, dass das FBI, sagen wir mal, bei Falschinformationen zu Corona wahrscheinlich eine etwas zu große Liste an Twitter geschickt hat,
Falschinformationen zu Corona und Wahl, ja. Da hat halt irgendwie jemand zum Beispiel getwittert, ich zähle in meinem Staat die Stimmzettel aus,
Und wenn du keine Maske trägst, dann zähle ich deine Stimme nicht.
Oder für jeden negativen Kommentar unter diese Stimme zähle ich eine Stimme mehr für die
Demokraten. Unter meinem Tweet zähle ich eine Stimme mehr für die Demokraten. Ja, das ist natürlich schon erkennbar lustig.
Gleichzeitig kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass so das Lager Trump hier, dass dem Lager
hier das humoristische Feingefühl fehlt und dann hat es FBI halt diese Tweets gemeldet.
Außerdem hat Twitter tatsächlich 3,4 Millionen US-Dollar vom FBI bekommen 2019 im Rahmen eines,
Programmes, wo sie Schadens-, oder Reimbursement, wie übersetzt man das? Also Entlohnung, Erstattung,
ja, genau, Erstattung für die Kosten bekommen haben, FBI-Requests zu behandeln. So, jetzt.
Denkt man sich so, ok, krass, das FBI zahlt dreieinhalb Millionen US-Dollar an Twitter
für Requests, dann werden sie eine ganze Menge gestellt haben.
Das ist aber auch der einzig zulässige Schluss, denn Alex Stammers, der war bei Facebook der
Chief Security Officer und ist insgesamt ein sehr gut beleumdeter IT-Security- und Social
Network-Security-Experte, sagte, das hat absolut nichts mit Content-Moderation zu tun.
Also es ist jetzt nicht irgendwie, dass das FBI gesagt hat, ey danke, dass ihr diese
Accounts schlecht gemacht habt und die gut, dafür kriegt ihr jetzt dreieinhalb Millionen,
sondern tatsächlich mit Processing-Kosten von, gib mal die Daten von dem, wir wollen hier diese Dinge haben.
Aber es zeigt natürlich, dass das FBI hier immerhin Twitter Arbeit für dreieinhalb Millionen
macht und die Gebühren werden nicht niedrig, aber angemessen sein. Bei dreieinhalb Millionen zeigt das natürlich schon, dass das FBI da offensichtlich eine
ganze Menge Requests hatte.
Auf jeden Fall ein paar Hunderttausend.
Da gibt es eben eine Zusammenarbeit. Absolut schockierende Neuigkeiten.
Entsprechend wurden sie ja dann auch irgendwie in einigen Newsseiten behandelt, wurde darüber berichtet. Offenbar kennen wir jetzt Zahlen dieser Einflussnahme, aber dass es die gab, hat jetzt niemanden
erschüttert.
Das war's für heute.
Und wenn Alex Stamos sagt, naja, also die Preise kommt mir ganz realistisch vor, dann weißt du, was bei Facebook gezahlt wird.
Kommen wir zu neuen Nachrichten von Captain Obvious. Die Associated Press hat mal zusammengezählt, in welchen Ländern so Corona-Überwachungsmaßnahmen jetzt zweckentfremdet werden. Das ist genau das, was wir vorhergesagt haben, weshalb wir uns bei der Corona-Warn-App in
Deutschland so eingebracht haben, daraus kein Überwachungstool zu machen.
Und ja, das war ja eine gute Nachricht. Das ist halt auch nicht passiert. Also wir haben eine funktionale Corona-Warn-App ohne zentralisierte Überwachung erkämpft
in Deutschland.
Und das ist eine Erfolgsgeschichte, die natürlich so vor den traurigen Nachrichten der Zeit
so ein bisschen untergeht. Aber ja, haben wir geschafft.
Und das war wahrscheinlich einer der größten netzpolitischen Erfolge der letzten Jahre.
So traurig ist das sozusagen. Aber ja, haben wir geschafft.
Und was kriegen wir jetzt von der O.S.S.P. berichtet? Ja, in Israel wurden Menschen mittels
Telefonüberwachung drangsaliert, die eigentlich für die Corona-Bekämpfung benutzt werden sollte. Aber da gibt es dann irgendwie, haben sie irgendwie Leuten Nachrichten geschickt,
die bei bestimmten Protesten waren. Also gab es offenbar irgendwie einen Prozess, der irgendwie
in einen Kampf ausgeartet ist an der Al-Aqsa Moschee und da haben sie den Leuten eine SMS
geschickt. Und die Rechte dazu, das zu tun, war halt eigentlich, die hatten sie wegen Corona und
nicht dafür. Indien nutzt die Methoden zur Strafverfolgung, da hatten sie sogar Gesichtserkennung.
In China haben sie das genutzt, um die Anreise zu Protesten zu verhindern. Da haben also Leute,
die sich zu Prozesten in Shengzhou bewegt haben, plötzlich eine rote Warnung in der Corona-App,
gehabt. Und dann kam die Polizei und hat gesagt, du hast ja eine rote Warnung, wo machst du den,
hier und hat dann quasi die Menschen festgenommen auf dem Weg zum Protest. Und das waren Menschen,
die ihre Reisepläne in der App hinterlegt hatten. Deswegen wussten sie auch ziemlich genau.
Dass sie sich jetzt dorthin bewegen und im Zweifelsfall mit welchen Zwecken mehr als 1300,
Personen, die demonstrieren wollten, haben das eben in Schengen-Zhao erlebt. Und ja, in Australien,
haben die Geheimdienste Daten aus der Covid-Safe-App abgegriffen. In Deutschland ja auch, aus den
ersten, also nicht den Apps, sondern den Systemen wie Luca. Und bei Luca haben sie ja, glaube ich,
auch auf die Daten zugegriffen, mithilfe der entsprechenden Ämter. Das heißt, ja,
du machst eine zentrale Datensammlung und was dann passiert, Leute greifen darauf zu. Du wächst
damit Begehrlichkeit und das war genau der Grund, warum wir das verhindern wollten. Das ist genau
der Grund, warum wir das getan haben und diese Sorge war nicht unbegründet, wie wir jetzt in den
Ländern sehen, die diesen Kampf nicht erfolgreich gekämpft haben.
Aber das muss man sich merken.
Das sind die Dinge, die man sich merken muss, weil die werden demnächst wieder mit irgendwelchen
zentralisierten Datensammlungen kommen. Und dann muss man sagen, wisst ihr noch damals, wir haben mit euch gesagt und wir haben es geschafft, wir haben es geschafft mit dem Protest einer sinnvolle Alternative, die auch funktioniert hat, zu schaffen.
Und ja, in anderen Staaten wurde das nicht gemacht und da wurden dann eben auch diese zentralen Datensammlungen missbraucht.
Kein Zweifel, dass die blöden Ideen von gestern alle nochmal auf den Tisch kommen.
Das ist...
In Berlin wollen sie jetzt auch schon wieder Blockchainzeugte zu machen.
Ihr Sach, mach du die Black-Chan-Meldung!
Die Leute, meine Blockchain-Mildung. Ach ja.
Mr. Bankman Fraud, wie man ihn jetzt wahrscheinlich nennen muss. Nein, Sam Bankman Fried, das ist dieser Nerd, der irgendwie in der Bundespolitik berichtete, diese Kryptobörse und Investmentkomplex,
FTX hochgezogen hat und binnen zwei Jahren auch schon wieder komplett versenkt bekommen hat.
Wo jetzt irgendwie Milliarden an Schulden an Kunden quasi auf der Rechnung stehen,
die halt einfach ihr Geld dort rein investiert haben, indem sie halt seine Krypto-Tokens gekauft haben, FTT und andere Maßnahmen. Und dieser ganze Konzern aus hunderten von Firmen, den er da innerhalb von zwei Jahren zusammengestrickt hat, der ist also jetzt komplett untergegangen.
Und die US-Gerichtsmaschine läuft jetzt auf Hochtouren.
Es wurde dann erstmal ein Haftbefehl ausgestellt in den Bahamas, wo er sich aufgehalten hat. Daraufhin haben die Autoritäten in Bahamas ihn auch festgenommen.
Dann gab es einen Auslieferungsantrag, jetzt ist er auch ausgeliefert worden.
Ja und durfte aber dann auch erstmal für schlappe 250 Millionen Dollar auf Kaution
frei, also im Sinne von der muss jetzt erstmal nicht irgendwo im Knast rumlungern, aber kriegt halt so eine schöne Fußfessel, wir erinnern uns, macht da wahrscheinlich Crowdfunding für eine Flex irgendwie und wartet auf die nächsten Schritte.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Das hat natürlich auch sehr viel, wie nennt man das, Argwohn geweckt, dass der in der Lage ist,
für 250 Millionen Kautionen sich dem Knast der Untersuchungshaft zu entziehen. Weil er ja im November gesagt hat, er hätte quasi nichts, vielleicht so 100.000 auf der Bank.
Ja, also was auch für viele Leute schon mal eine komplett neue Definition von fast nichts
ist. Ja, aber das auf jeden Fall viel, viel, viel eher fast nichts als 250 Millionen.
Tatsächlich hat er diese 250 Millionen durch einen Bail Bond bekommen.
Ja, das heißt, da wurde, da kommt jetzt als Sicherheit das Haus seiner Eltern ist gesetzt
dafür, dass jemand anders dieses 250 Millionen Risiko eingeht. Und solange wie dieses Bail-Risiko
besteht, werden die darauf, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, zahlen, die dann halt Zinsen. Das
heißt selbstverständlich haben die Amerikaner auch aus Untersuchungshafts-Bail ein Zinsgeschäft
gemacht, was die Banken irgendwie für dich absichern. Also der hat nicht 250 Millionen,
sicher locker gemacht.
Also das ist da in den USA ohnehin eine gängige Geschichte, solche Bail-Bonds,
weil das viele Leute in Anspruch nehmen müssen, die halt einfach mal so von der Polizei erstmal in Knast geworfen werden,
weil, keine Ahnung, der Hautton nicht die richtige Tönung hatte in dem Moment. Und wenn du dann quasi keine eigenen Mittel hast in dem Moment,
dann willst du halt auch schnell wieder rauskommen, weil du ansonsten halt gleich deinen Job verlierst, etc. pp.
Und dann gibt es halt um die Gefängnisse herum dann so ganze Straßen von irgendwelchen Lawyern, die dir dann halt mal ebenso deine Kaution stellen, aber halt zu absurden Preisen.
Und dann musst du natürlich dann entsprechend viel Zinsen abdrücken. Das dürfte sich hier auch ganz gut summieren bei 250 Millionen Dollar.
Also, naja, auf jeden Fall die ganze Untersuchung dieses Falls geht kräftig voran. Zwischenzeitlich ist auch nochmal bekannt geworden, dass er wohl auch ganz ordentlich ausgeteilt hat Geld an politische Parteien.
Und zwar sowohl an Republikaner als auch an Demokraten.
Vielleicht jetzt nicht so ungewöhnlich, aber auf jeden Fall so ein deutliches Zeichen, dass es einem jetzt gar nicht darum geht, eine Kunden... Value Divesting. Erklär mal.
Das ist Value Divesting.
Heißt das nicht, dass man...
Nee, Entschuldigung, das ist falsch.
Moment. Sorry, das ist falsch. Ich habe einfach gerade den falschen Beruf genutzt.
Was es auf jeden Fall meiner Meinung nach bedeutet, ist, dass sie einfach Einfluss nehmen wollten auf die Politik in den USA insgesamt, weil sie natürlich befürchten müssen, dass ganze Krypto-Kram weiter reguliert wird. Da hat er jetzt glaube ich auch die richtige Vorlage für
geliefert mit diesem ganzen Hoax und mittelfristig glaube ich muss sich diese ganze Branche darauf
einstellen, im zunehmenden Maße genauso reguliert zu werden wie der sonstige Finanzbereich auch, weil sonst einfach alles wild läuft.
Und der Begriff, den ich gesucht habe, ist Asset Diversification.
Also er hat in beide politischen Parteien investiert, um das Risiko auszugleichen, dass
eines dieser beiden Investments sich als Fehler erweist. Und wenn du halt in beide politischen Parteien investiert hast, dann fährst du erst mal ganz gut. Ja.
Ja, sehr viel mehr gibt es dazu nicht zu berichten, außer dass natürlich diese ganze
FTX-Geschichte diese ganze Kryptobranche gerade so in Schock packt.
So und man kann davon ausgehen, dass hier noch eine ganze Menge Domino-Effekt ausgespielt werden kann, weil natürlich das Vertrauen jetzt auch in die ganzen anderen Buden entsprechend gering ist und der fortwährend niedrige Preis für diese ganzen Crypto-Assets, also der,
Bitcoinpreis etc. die sind ja permanent gesunken.
15.000 Grad.
Immer noch viel im Vergleich zu vor zehn Jahren, aber nicht im Ansatz mehr zu vergleichen mit dem Hype von 2021, wo er bei 60.000 war.
Und das macht natürlich auch diese ganzen Business Modelle, die da in den letzten Jahren losgetreten wurden, insbesondere das Verleihen von Krypto-Geld, aber eben
auch generell das Schürfen von Bitcoins, was ja extrem energieaufwendig ist.
Und jetzt hast du auf der einen Seite die Energiekosten, die weltweit steigen, und auf der anderen Seite einen fallenden Bitcoin-Preis.
Das heißt, mit den paar Bitcoins, die du dann aus dieser Schürferei gewinnst, kannst du dann auch noch nicht mal mehr genug Geld machen, um noch die steigenden Energiekosten zu zahlen.
Also das sieht nicht so optimal aus für diese Branche.
Und wenn es nach mir geht, gerne weiter so.
Als der Bankman Fried verhaftet wurde auf den Bahamas,
stellte, irgendwie hab ich irgendwo in so einer Online-Seite gelesen, ob die Kunden ihre Milliarden zurückbekommen, ist noch offen.
Das würde ich in Zweifel ziehen, ob das noch offen ist.
Da würde ich vorsichtig sagen, das ist nicht mehr offen. Ich glaube, das ist nicht mehr offen.
Die Wette, also wenn das noch offen ist, dann ist das ein verdammt schmaler Spalt.
Ich denke auch, das könnte schwierig werden.
Ja, auch durch einen sehr schmalen Spalt gab es Eindringlinge.
Das war mein erster Tipp für die Nase.
Bei Passwort Vault Speicher. Was? Oder hast du noch was zu Bankman Free?
Du hast es gesagt.
Nee, ich wollte auf LastPass weiterleiten. Genau, LastPass ist so ein Passwort Wallet Unternehmen, wo man halt, so ähnlich wie auch bei One Passwort, was vielleicht noch mehr Leute.
Jaja, jaja.
Kennen halt so, ja, hosted sein Schlüsselset abspeichern kann, um da convenient von überall drauf zugreifen zu können. Natürlich verschlüsselt. Zumindest geht man davon aus, dass das weitgehend,
verschlüsselt ist. Ja, aber die hatten jetzt einen Hack zu beklagen, wo irgendjemand Zugriff erlangt hat auf so Third-Party Cloud Storage, wo halt Vaults rumlagen, also solche Schlüsselansammlungen
von Kunden und zumindest so weit drauf zugreifen konnte, dass eben dann die nicht so verschlüsselten,
Dinge in diesen Vaults offen lagen. Also da ist von Kundenmetadaten die Rede von URLs.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was Sie damit meinen.
Ne, doch, das ist erkennbar. Also, wenn dir das Dateiformat von so einem Password-Save, ne,
der verschlüsselt die Nutzernamen und die Passwörter, aber der verschlüsselt nicht, für welche Seite das gilt. Denn wenn du jetzt mit deinem Password-Save, sagen wir mal,
suchst du jetzt eine Webseite, ja, dann bietet die ja zum Beispiel, iOS macht das auch,
Der kann dir ja dann anbieten und sagen, ich habe hier einen Account für, wenn du möchtest.
Und wenn du mich entsperrst, dann gebe ich dir den auch. Und deswegen sind quasi die Domains, für die diese Passwort-User-Namen-Kombination gelten,
nicht verschlüsselt. Damit der eben auch im unverschlüsselten Zustand dir sagen kann, habe ich was oder habe ich nichts.
Damit hast du jetzt quasi, aber diese Domains sind ja, zumindest wenn es irgendwie um Webkram geht,
ohnehin öffentlich im weitesten Sinne.
Das ist in der Regel bekannt, dass man sich dort anmelden kann.
Ja, na gut, also meine Vodun-Account hast du natürlich auch schon mal eine Information.
Insofern ist das ja.
Aus diesem Grund habe ich das jetzt aber so verstanden, dass sie, also eigentlich kannst du vom Glück sagen,
dass sie den Username mit verschlüsselt haben.
Und ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob das jeder macht.
Das weiß ich jetzt auch nicht. Ich meine, ich kann mir allerdings auch ein System vorstellen, wo auch die URLs noch mit verschlüsselt sind, dass du sozusagen so einen zweistufigen Zugang machst. Ich meine, wenn du das eher auf deinem Rechner machst.
Du kannst ja auch sagen, du musst, um überhaupt erst mal das Angeboten zu bekommen, dass du dich irgendwo mit dem gespeicherten Passwort anloggen kannst, musst du überhaupt erst mal so einen Privolt eröffnen.
Du musst erst mal generell deinen Passwortmanager in so einer ersten Stufe,
anloggt haben, um überhaupt auf die URLs zugreifen zu können, um dieses Matching zu machen. und wenn du dann nochmal auf ein Passwort zugreifen willst, dann musst du es halt nochmal,
separat autorisieren. Aber ich habe mir ehrlich gesagt über die Betriebssystemintegration im Detail noch nicht so viel Gedanken gemacht, ob das dann noch irgendwelche Grenzen der nutzbarkeit hat aber auf jeden fall ist das passiert und das natürlich doof.
Außerdem haben sie die Namen, Rechnungsadressen, E-Mail-Adressen, Telefonnummern, IP-Adressen
von Nutzern, also von Usern bei LastPass und dann eben die Vaults. Die sind aber unencrypted, also die URL sind unencrypted und die alles, Username und Password,
und so weiter ist alles encrypted. Ja, das ist natürlich jetzt, ich sag mal, das ist jetzt die
die Probe aufs Exempel. Ich meine, dafür nutzt man sowas. Jetzt sind natürlich die dran, die,
potentiell schlechte Passwörter für ihren Passwortsafe hatten. Wenn du da jetzt irgendwie
ein schlechtes Passwort hast, was potentiell knackbar ist und die machen sich die Mühe jetzt
da drüber zu laufen, dann hast du halt einen geknackten Passwortsafe. Auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen, grundsätzlich, also natürlich ist das, also das ist schlecht und das ist,
beunruhigend, ja, aber es ist jetzt noch kein Grund durchzudrehen, weil es, wenn die alles
richtig gemacht haben, wo du von ausgehen muss, also solltest, dann hast du jetzt irgendwie 256
mit AES-Verschlüsselung und das wird so schnell keiner knacken.
Und ich wäre ich, also deswegen verschlüsselt man den ja.
Also es wäre jetzt ganz grundsätzlich könnte man sagen, die haben jetzt halt das, also der größte anzunehmende Unglücksfall ist eingetreten und der wird nicht schlimm sein.
Und genau deswegen hat man diese Password-Sales verschlüsselt.
Also es könnte sein, dass das jetzt genau zeigt, warum man so ein Password Safe haben will.
Gleichzeitig werden diejenigen sagen, die ihre Password Safes lokal halten und nicht über die
Cloud synchronisieren, werden natürlich sagen, genau deswegen hat man Password Safe nicht in der
Cloud. Diejenigen hätten dieses Problem überhaupt nicht.
Das ist ja immer die Abwägung zwischen einfacher Benutzbarkeit eines solchen Features,
damit man es überhaupt erstmal benutzen kann und dann auch immer benutzt, versus erhöhter Sicherheit. Und Sicherheit und Convenience gehen immer so ein bisschen gegenläufig.
Ich finde, du hast gerade etwas sehr Wichtiges gesagt.
Die können gerne mal gegenläufig sein, aber diejenigen, die auf den Komfort von Last
Pass verzichten, bewegen sich potenziell in weniger sichere Bereiche. Ja, also diese Synchronisierung hat ein Sicherheitsrisiko.
Dieses Sicherheitsrisiko hat sich hier jetzt gerade manifestiert.
Die Saves wurden massenhaft runtergeladen.
Dafür waren sie aber nun mal auch verschlüsselt. Hättest du auf die Synchronisierung verzichtet, hättest du erst mal Abstriche in Convenience gehabt.
Nämlich zum Beispiel was weiß ich, LastPass synchronisiert sich nicht zwischen deinen Geräten.
Die haben, soweit ich das weiß, auch so Möglichkeiten, dass du jetzt halt Passwörter mal kurzzeitig
mit anderen Benutzergruppen shares. Also wenn es jetzt Funktionsaccounts gibt, bei denen du die Passwörter regelmäßig änderst,
dann kannst du über die Cloud eben sicherstellen, dass heute darf der Linus mal das Passwort haben oder so.
Und danach wird es geändert. Wenn du diese ganzen Komforten nicht gehabt hättest, kann es halt sein, dass du einfach überhaupt nicht LastPass genutzt hätte oder überhaupt kein Passwortmanager.
Das heißt, die haben durch diesen Komfort vermutlich dafür gesorgt, dass relativ viele
Menschen oder Unternehmen Passwortmanager nutzen, die das sonst nicht getan hätten.
Und wenn Sie jetzt Ihren Kram richtig implementiert haben, dann können Sie sagen,
SETA, deswegen wird das verschlüsselt und wenn sie es nicht sicher implementiert haben,
dann werden wir es bald wissen, weil dann geht es richtig rund.
Aber ich finde, also mir ist halt wichtig an dieser Stelle, das richtig einzusortieren,
weil potentiell Leute das halt als Grund nehmen oder als Anlass sehen könnten,
der dagegen die Verwendung von Passwortmanagern spricht. Und ich würde sagen nein. Also die
Alternative, keinen Passwortmanager zu haben, ist auf jeden Fall die schlechtere.
Ja, dann der Guardian hat offenbar eine Ransomware-Angriff. Das ist die Schaffens aber,
ihre Webseite und so weiter aufrecht zu erhalten, aber sind gut getroffen und im Ausnahmezustand.
Und da muss man sich sowieso mal überlegen, also das ist ja ein Geschäftsmodell,
Ransomware, das tatsächlich jedes Jahr echt wächst.
Die Fälle, die man da so hat, ich bin ja jetzt auch in dieser Branche tätig,
das nimmt wirklich einfach seit Jahren zu und dies wird seit Jahren schlimmer.
Und gleichzeitig bin ich wirklich einfach nur erstaunt, wirklich erstaunt, wie wenige Unternehmen da ernsthaft sich auseinandersetzen und sich dagegen schützen, bevor es passiert ist.
Und ich bin teilweise auch erstaunt, wie wenig Unternehmen, selbst wenn es ihnen passiert ist, danach, sage ich mal, sich bemühen, einen adäquaten Schutz zu erlangen.
Das ist mitunter echt erschreckend. Und das ist, finde ich, irgendwie kaum nachvollziehbar.
Also die, wir haben ja hier schon darüber gesprochen, dass Versicherungen diese Lösegeldzahlungen.
In der Regel nicht decken und bzw. sich zumindest nicht in ihren Vertragswerken dazu verpflichten,
lassen, die zu decken. Das heißt, die zahlen das vielleicht, aber nur wenn sie sehen,
dass dadurch wirklich ein großer anderer Schaden für sie abgewendet werden kann, den sie sonst decken müssten. Also nur wenn sie sehen, okay, das ist das kleinere Übel.
Aber wenn das so ist, dass du durch Ransomware immer das Zahlen das kleinere Übel ist, dann
hast du als Versicherter auf jeden Fall auch Dinge falsch gemacht. Und dazu kommen ja dann jetzt diese in den USA, also es ist ja wegen potenzieller Finanzierung
von Terrorismus ohnehin quasi jetzt illegal ohne Zustimmung.
Das heißt, das wird ja zustimmungspflichtig.
Also wenn du nicht vorher mit der Regierung darüber redest, dass du das bezahlst und dir quasi eine Genehmigung holst, dann bist du schon im illegalen Bereich. Und es ist, ja,
ich finde es tatsächlich faszinierend, dass so viele Unternehmen von diesem Risiko wissen.
Und Angreifer dann doch in der Regel einen relativ einfachen Durchmarsch haben. Siehe,
Continental, die sind jetzt auch seit einigen Wochen damit in den Nachrichten, dass sie einen solchen Vorfall bei sich hatten, mit sehr schnell eben oder inzwischen nur noch Millionensummen,
die da gefordert werden, weil die Angreifer sich auf größere Unternehmen spezialisieren.
Und ja, ich kann nur sagen, dass es mich fasziniert, weil so schwer ist das jetzt auch nicht, also sich dagegen zu schützen.
Prävention, paar Sachen, Detektion kannst du was machen und dann natürlich einfach,
Wiederherstellungsmaßnahmen, Proben, Üben, sicherstellen.
Vor allem, es geht nicht darum, alle deine Daten in Sicherheit zu haben.
Da sind dann am Ende, weiß ich nicht, hunderte Gigabytes verschlüsselt, von denen dich aber am Ende eh nur, sagen wir mal, acht Gigabyte wirklich interessieren,
weil das die sind, die du brauchst, um morgen weiterarbeiten zu können.
Und da kann man natürlich mit Wiederanlaufkonzepten Und eine Überlegung, wie man sein Unternehmen aufbaut, was man hier hat, was führt zu einer
Betriebsunterbrechung, wie sichert man das, wie sichert man dafür, dass das Backup nicht
in der Domäne hängt und solche Dinge. Das sind jetzt alles keine Geheimnisse.
Und das kannst du in Zeiten des Friedens halt auch mit moderatem Aufwand für deine IT oder
für dein Unternehmen erreichen, diesen Schutz. Aber es scheint heute noch immer keinen so ernsthaft zu interessieren.
Was würdest du denn sagen, ist die Quote von Unternehmen, die von so einem Angriff schon mal betroffen waren, die dann auch,
entsprechende Maßnahmen erfolgreich ergriffen haben. Also lernen da auch alle draus, weil...
Naja, ob die erfolgreich sind, die Maßnahmen, weißt ja immer erst.
Na ja gut, sagen wir mal so, wie viele Fälle kennst du, wo es dann nach einer Zeit, die eigentlich auch hätte ausreichen müssen, sich gegen eine Attacke zu wehren, noch mal unter die Räder kam? ist das sozusagen genauso gängig?
Also es gibt Fälle, wo dann eine andere Gänge einfach ein Jahr später einmarschiert ist,
weil sie nicht daraus gelernt haben. Aber ich kann schon sagen, dass ich einen nennenswerten Anteil an Unternehmen kenne, die dann nach einem solchen Fall irrationalerweise sagen,
jetzt haben wir es hinter uns, jetzt kann uns das nicht nochmal passieren.
Hahahaha.
Ohne die entsprechenden Maßnahmen ergriffen zu haben.
Ahhhh,
Ich hatte doch schon Corona.
Also so was in der Richtung.
Vielleicht kurz, wenn wir jetzt tatsächlich ein bisschen darüber reden.
Also wie funktioniert so ein Angriff? Du schickst, du schaffst es in der Regel durch Social Engineering, irgendwie Leute dazu zu bringen, deinen initialen Foothold auszuführen. Dann hast du halt irgendwie einen Trojaner da drauf.
Was weiß ich, Metapreter, Cobaltstrike oder irgendwas selber Gebasteltes.
Dafür brauchst du einen Dropper.
Nehmen wir mal einfaches Beispiel, was jetzt in den letzten Jahren vorherrschend war.
Office Dokument mit dem Makro. Jetzt kannst du als allererstes mal fragen, wie viele Unternehmen haben Makros deaktiviert
in Office? Keins.
So gut wie niemand. Weil es gibt irgendwie eine Abteilung, die das braucht. Aber du gehst hin und deswegen erlaubst du Makros im kompletten Unternehmen.
Das haben sie dann vielleicht irgendwann mal gelernt. Natürlich kannst du dann auf deinem E-Mail Gateway entsprechende Scanner haben, die sowas entdecken oder so.
Meistens auch nicht. Aber so, jetzt wird die Shared Software ausgeführt.
Jetzt hat der Angreifer Zugriff auf diesen Rechner mit diesem User-Account. Dann machst du irgendwelche Problemchen.
Oder dann versuchst du erst mal lokale Admin-Rechte zu kriegen.
Häufig ist das lokale Admin-Passwort halt doch relativ einfach, sodass du es geknackt bekommst.
Bei denen, wo es nicht der Fall ist, oder also bei denen, wo es nicht der Fall ist,
versuchst du dich halt irgendwie weiter lateral zu bewegen und guckst dir vor allem dann das Active Directory an. Das scannst du im Prinzip die kompletten Nutzerrechte und so weiter, was du
da alles bekommst und findest einfache Pfade, Domänenadmin-Rechte zu bekommen. Ja, also von einer Gruppe in die nächste, wer hat überhaupt die Rechte und so weiter. Und da findest du häufig
auch irgendwelche komischen Windows, hast du nicht gesehen, Server, wo irgendeine Applikation
läuft, wo der User Domänenrechte hat oder sonst was. Oder du schaffst zum Beispiel Probleme auf
einem Rechner, um dann Leute dazu zu bringen, dass deine administrative Tätigkeit notwendig ist.
Jetzt gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder die Leute melden sich dann mit einem lokalen Admin an,
oder sie melden sich direkt mit einem Domänenadmin an. Und bei der Gelegenheit mopsst du dir das,
Passwort, weil du halt schon eine Chartsoftware hast, die Tastatureingaben abgreift oder so. Und dann bist du Domänenadmin. Das heißt, du kontrollierst die gesamte Flotte. Dann guckst du,
wo ist denn hier der Backup-Server und sagst dem Backup-Server, so ungefähr formatier mal die,
Platte. Und wenn der Backup-Server alle Backups gelöscht hat, dann rollst du einfach nur noch,
per Gruppenrichtlinie aus, dass jetzt alles verschlüsselt wird. Und dann wartest du, dass sie sich bei dir melden und bereit sind, mit dir zu verhandeln. Und das ist immer das
Gleiche. Das heißt, um dich zu schützen, du willst die Chart-Software erkennen, du willst den Backup-Server nicht in der Domäne hängen haben und du willst das Active Directory so,
konfiguriert haben, dass es da halt verschiedene Tears gibt und es nicht so ohne Weiteres möglich ist, irgendeinen Server zu übernehmen und sich von da aus Domain-Admin-Rechte zu holen. Das weiß
jeder, das ist seit vielen Jahren das gleiche und wenn du jetzt Leuten erzählst und sagst,
pass auf, wäre zum Beispiel sinnvoll, wenn eure Admins sich nicht den ganzen Tag mit Domain-Admin-
Rechten überall anmelden würden. Ja, ich weiß, dann wird diesem Anspruch halt nicht gefolgt.
Fertig.
Und das wissen die und das wird jahrelang so gehändelt.
Und wenn dann, wenn es dann schief geht und diese ganze Sache da liegt, dann ist das Geschrei groß. So, wenn dann das Geschrei wieder klein ist, weil man irgendwie sich aus dem Inzident rausgekämpft hat, dann ist halt die Frage, wenn man sagt, so Leute, wie sieht es denn aus, wollen wir jetzt mal vielleicht die Sache hier in Ordnung bringen?
Und dann ist halt so, hapf, hie, gerade schlecht und jetzt läuft es ja erstmal, ne? Und außerdem haben wir gerade ein paar Millionen gezahlt, jetzt sitzt die Cola auch nicht mehr so gut.
Und dann findest du teilweise Unternehmen, die zum Beispiel vor vier Jahren ein Ransomware
Incident hatten und seitdem noch nicht mal das Active Directory neu aufgezogen haben.
Ich finde es faszinierend, dass das in keiner Form berücksichtigt wird.
Ja, und dann musst du zahlen. Das ist das Problem.
Und das ist seit Jahren massive Schäden. Jeder weiß, dass das passiert. Aber so interessiert irgendwie kein.
Dann nehmen wir so zur Kenntnis. Kost of Business.
Aber es gibt natürlich auch hier wieder ein Lichtstreifen am Horizont für von Ransomware betroffenen Unternehmen.
Denn es gibt jetzt in den USA ein Unternehmen, das heißt Do Not Pay und das ist dafür da, für dich auszuhandeln, dass du irgendwas nicht bezahlen musst.
Und sie bezahlen sich als die weltersten Roboteranwalt und setzen unter anderem Chat-GPT wohl ein,
um hier sich mit so Online-Supportchats zu unterhalten. Wenn du dann irgendwie den Plugin installiert hast und du bist so in deinem typischen, was weiß ich hier,
ich rede mit meinem Supporter bei Dollarfirma, wo ich einen Vertrag habe, dann kannst du irgendwie so ihr Plugin aktivieren und dann sagen, ich möchte nicht mehr so viel bezahlen. Und dann fängt
irgendwie das Ding automatisch an, mit deinem Support gegenüber zu quatschen. Und ja, ja, das ist jetzt so ein
bisschen viral gegangen, weil die irgendwie so ein Video gepostet haben, wie das dann so abgelaufen ist, wo so eine erfundene Entität oder beziehungsweise ein echter Customer sozusagen dieses Plugin hat reden lassen bei Comcast mit einem entsprechenden Support-Mitarbeiter bzw. es fing erstmal an mit
dem Standard-Bot und dann schaltet das Plugin automatisch auf, ich möchte jetzt hier mit einer richtigen Person reden und dann kommt es ja gleich an so, ja mein Internet ist ausgefallen, es lief irgendwie tagelang nicht und hier so und so viele Leute haben euch schon verklagt,
Deswegen und wenn ihr mir jetzt nicht einen besseren preis gibt und so dann schlage ich zu und dann verklage ich euch alle und so weiter und so ja ich muss mal kurz gucken was ich da tun kann.
Siehst du so richtig auf der anderen seite schon die schwitzende person.
Naja und dann nach ein paar dialogen.
Solange auf der anderen Seite noch jemand schwitzt, weil das wird natürlich...
Das wird ein Bot worden natürlich werden.
Das wird halt Alpha Go, ne? Also spielt einfach lange genug gegen sich selber.
Klar.
The drone wars have begun. Begonnen. The drone wars have.
Dann geht's irgendwie richtig los. Also es ist natürlich eine ganz interessante Geschichte wieder. Vielleicht könnte man ja dann bei der Ransomware irgendwie dann mit den Verhandlungen, mit
mit den Bitcoin-Erpressern irgendwie ein Chut-GPT machen lassen.
Ja, das kann man auch mit denen verhandeln.
Aber gibt es auch Unternehmen, die das professionell anbieten? Ja, die verhandeln nicht nur Ransomware, sondern die rüben sich dann auch damit zu
verhandeln, wenn irgend einer Geise genommen hat oder so.
Der Herr Kleiderskiz.
Gut, das war also als kleine Aufhellung noch zum Ende der Sendung. Ansonsten denke ich mal,
können wir den Sack jetzt hier zumachen, damit ihr wieder die Zeit findet, den Sack wieder aufzumachen.
Und ich erweihnachte den jetzt nicht. Da wollen wir euch da nicht weiter belegen. Mit anderen Worten, nächste Woche gibt es auf jeden Fall keine Sendung, das werdet ihr euch wahrscheinlich schon gedacht
haben. Geschweige denn auch nur die Bereitschaft gehabt zu haben, sie anzuhören, wenn wir sie dann doch rausgebracht hätten. Ja, nee, so seid ihr ja nicht. Ihr hört ja alles, was wir hier zu erzählen haben. Selbst wenn wir nichts zu erzählen haben.
Genau. Auf das alle eure Wünsche für 2023 in Füllung gehen.
Ja, dann wünschen wir einen guten Rutsch.
Und dass mir keiner mit diesem Do-Not-Pay in den E-Meter-Ebene-Shop kommt.
Genau. Do not donate. Ne, also wir bedanken uns bei euch für dieses weitere Jahr, dem
ihr uns hier bei uns im Unsinn, den wir hier von uns geben, bei uns bei uns bei uns im Unsinn,
den wir hier von uns geben und das auch alles unterstützen auf die eine oder an die andere Art und Weise, sei es mit klugen Kommentaren oder nicht so klugen Kommentaren, Informationen,
Hintergrundinformationen, die wir ja auch immer wieder bekommen, Richtigstellungen und ja und natürlich auch Spenden und T-Shirt-Käufe, haben wir eigentlich schon unsere T-Shirts erwähnt,
Insofern wünschen wir euch ein frohes Malsther. Bis bald.
Ich glaube, das haben wir jetzt dieses Mal oft genug gemacht.